or than 8 inches could fall today in New
York City classes are canceled for more
than a million public school students
this massive storm is slamming the
mid-atlantic states right now Tony de
copal is in Cape May New Jersey where
snow has been falling since last night
Tony good morning to you good morning if
you want to call it morning it is cold
it is blustery it has been snowing here
in Cape May for hours there's a wind
gusts of about 30 miles an hour I can
tell you that sandy here on the beach it
feels much it is stronger than that and
did I mention it's cold well about 150
feet out there in Delaware Bay it is
actually frozen over you can walk on it
that is how thick the ice is there
supposed to be a ferry out there it
hasn't run for a couple days they're not
sure when it's gonna run again and north
of here where you guys are are in New
York City they've got about eight inches
expected starting during the morning
rush worst time possible right 1500
plows are at work to try to make the
city passable they're working across all
five boroughs and even when this snow
disappears even when it's all gone the
eastern seaboard is still going to be
dealing with temperatures struggling to
make it into the single digits gonna be
a very long morning and could be a very
long week Nora back to you alright Tony
thank you so much tough conditions out
there